Oh cute piggyback right hey guys Joey
here with another unboxing and today we
have present tech expert Michael hi I'm
here and Michael tell us what we're
gonna unbox today I got a treat for
y'all
mmm SNES classic edition Matt so this is
the coveted SNES classic edition it
comes with a bunch of different games
all from the 90s era right they're clean
one of my favorites Donkey Kong Country
corpse week nah that's messed up it's
not stuff now but I'm hyped up for Super
Mario RPG
yeah I'll play that again I've never
played it so this is gonna be my first
experience but yeah there's 21 games in
here including the never before released
Star Fox 2 so let's dig in show it let's
see what's in the box
this is snug hey all that's why I could
I can pull that out already wanting it
yeah
alright let's do this I can I treat so
we got ooh I got let me read y'all a
bedtime story
oh there's the instruction man has the
instruction manual
alright cool well what's in here you
should know had it oh is that the poster
actually it's got a sad if this is oh
wait oh it is ah cuz you know how like
some of the old games that used to come
with like full long as well as the
instruction manual they don't do it
anymore they don't even give you paper
you know you got a damn 12 digit code
that's it hold that up yeah look at that
oh it's kind of cute okay these are the
controllers right here oh let's see how
the spills I feel how you know that's
right Wow actually huh look at
well wait while we got the control let's
see how long the cord is yes I don't
know what they was thinking well yeah I
guess their idea was that since a lot of
Japanese systems you sat on the floor
with it so you didn't need to be all the
way on the couch alright yeah that
actually looks about like standard
length for the Super Nintendo
follow me see I'm about like six feet
tall I'm not standing on so that's as
well like what four five feet I don't
know four five feet not bad
got the USB power brick right there wait
what
that's a powered by USB oh no weird we
have these doesn't need that much juice
then right here is the the HDMI cable
oh yeah free HDMI cable as well as the
power cord right here which assume is
it's again the same way that looks like
they may extend it a lot of the cord
lengths for these and then finally oh we
got the would you do the honors yeah
we'll get my get my grubby hands all
over the bank oh my god that is so
adorable it's so cute
oh god wall it is my god I just want to
take it on a walk and get shot at right
there all right so we got all these non
functioning buttons wait no no
entrepreneur yeah this is that power
button that turns it on okay well what
are you gonna eject nothing this is all
I wish I wish the sounds like open even
though this dust yeah
so we got the old controller ports for
the Super Nintendo but since these ones
are a little bit too big for that it's a
little different it was a different
solution where you can actually just
take this entire section off having
trouble again okay there we go Oh
everything you can plug those in yeah
let's get it you go the other one all
you want to go one be one you want
three fighter oh no you got no no no not
again see you man Joey Gaul what me so
this thing may be small but I see that
you have something that we can compare
to right oh yes we got ourselves a real
SNES right here it's really yellow I had
don't mind how nasty you look this dirty
as hell but look how Oh father and son
right right there okay well let's take a
look at the like the actual size of them
and just how they look together is that
the this is the NES classic and this is
the original super Neos like that yeah
they seem pretty identical it looks like
they use the would seem I put appears to
be the exact same mold yeah I think to
make them buttons feel good so it's nest
classic is cute in all and it doesn't
really come with anything special other
than the poster end but the console self
special yeah but how does it actually
play oh snap we already got it up and
running
alright we looking at the UI here it's
very clean reminiscent of everything
else Nintendo
um but Joey let's look through all these
games we got so you got them in
alphabetic order contra 3 yeah Don Kim
country
earthbound f-zero phone that's two or
three breath Kirby super star yeah we
dream horse omegam Megaman X is the best
in Mega Man series sorry
secret - Star Fox - like it's all
wrapped up - oh don't you have to beat
starfox unlock I don't know I um I might
be trippin super Street fire or Street
Fighter 2 turbo super Castlevania for
Super Bowls and go Super Mario Kart yeah
Mario RPG all supers right here super
mario world super metroids punch-out
Legend of Zelda super super legend its
own and then
Yoshi's Island damn that's some good
some good let's check the contract
though you want play call yeah yeah okay
so for contra a game that requires a lot
of concentration precision this the
controls feel really good they're very
responsive the controllers at the
country alright since we died let's go
back to the menu in order to do that
looks like you actually have to hit the
reset button right there
hey the reset button actually well I
actually wish there was there's there a
way to do it through your controller no
it looks like you can only do it through
the console itself but what it does when
you actually hit reset it gives you a
little save point right there
so you can return to it later so we can
do a couple different filters right here
and a couple different frames so we can
do a regular four by three we can also
do pixel-perfect
apparently which makes everything I feel
I believe a square frame wait okay
square pixel all right yeah we also have
a CRT filter right here so you get those
sweet scan lines in fake-ass gammas 9 I
don't have that man oh we're turning on
what I have to do different frames so
looks like we got one galaxy themed if I
would in my like the woodgrain yeah I'm
all about the dots some colorful blocks
right there that's cute oh we got the
Edie's grid oh snap this is the one
we're gonna go with we got 15 inch
Kenwood's right there alright see you
the other options we can play a demo
while we're just in the menus and
actually let's let's show that so if you
just leave the system running in the
menu for about a minute or so something
cool what happened we're gonna wait oh
here you go oh dang chose the game for
us
thanks Mario so that's all you get in
this Nets classic vision box you got the
console two controllers sweet poster
that's all you need Joey how you feeling
feeling really great this looks to be
really cool the menu system is really
nice you know there's a ton of our
favorites of all time upon the classics
21 games and clean Star Fox - hope you
guys will be able to find it you know I
know they're hard to come by but just
keep trying you'll get it yep 80 bucks
comes out in September 29 yeah and good
luck finding one
yeah and for other unboxings make sure
to check out gamespot.com
you can see us there yeah see you guys
next time
[Music]